a Harley or Gavin Williamson some have
left his cabinet some still in them but
this is a real policy issue today but
there's so much politics around it and I
imagine that labor will go in on issues
around this brexit deal that is under
intense discussions uh both here and in
Brussels as well as in Northern Ireland
we'll be watching to see what the sum of
his back benches do some of the ERG the
Euro skeptic group the brexiteer group
in the party do they make any uh remarks
or questions to all the PM what does the
dup do because I have to say uh at the
end of last week when it was recess it
was all a go-go on this deal and and an
expectation put out really by number 10
that this could happen early this week
now since then the mood has soured quite
a lot with the brexite as I speak to one
of them said to me last night you can't
bulldoze a deal through you have to
pitch roll but they're trying to
bulldoze us we need to see the text
we're not going to agree to anything and
critically the dup have to be on board
and now it seems that there's some row
back from number 10 with potentially
this deal isn't going to happen this
week and and from people I've spoken to
the handling of it by number 10 if
anything has made it harder for the
Prime Minister now to get a deal with
the back benches so I'm looking out for
key brexiteers to see uh what they say
and whether they uh create problems for
the pm today maybe it might be one of
these pmqs where it's not so much The
Exchange in Springfield but actually
what the others questions in the back
benches say Beth thank you very much and
thank you very much Gary Sandberg
conservative MP Stephen kinnick for
labor and Stuart Housey for the s p for
giving us your thoughts ahead of prime
minister's questions we're going to take
a very short break but we will return to
the House of Commons as soon as the
Prime Minister takes to his feet at
midday stay with us for that
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we're going to be Crossing into the
House of Commons in a moment where prime
minister's questions is due to start but
we'll also be showing you Vladimir
Putin's rally in Moscow at the same time
and we'll bring you more of that after
pmqs finishes but for now let's cross
live to the commons where Rishi sunak is
expected to take his feet at any moment
our political editor Beth Rigby is here
he's been in the job now quite a few
months settling into it
will you settle into it but it could be
about to get a lot bumpier Jane because
of the issues around the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill uh problems about
the post-trade uh brexit trading
Arrangements uh in Northern Ireland and
this is an issue that's now come into a
head he's trying to get a deal uh before
the Good Friday agreement anniversary
the 25-year and agree anniversary and
he's coming up uh with some resistance
if you like from brexiteers on his
benches from the dup so it's not been
the easiest of starts for him anyway
there wasn't any honeymoon period for
Rishi sunaka now there's talk about is
it going to get a lot more difficult
because there's one uh senior brexit who
said to me last night if you can't get
the dep to agree the deal he can't get
the European research group to agree the
deal that group of brexitier back
benches then he's got a party management
problem and I think what you'll see
today here is kirstanmer asking lots of
questions on the deal and then doing the
whole I will get this through Parliament
you can have my votes but look what
happened with Theresa May when she got
into that situation eventually she was
full stamp of office so this is sort of
tricky times for the Prime Minister
moment of reflection which will give us
the opportunity to pay tribute to the
courage of the Ukrainian people and
demonstrate our solidarity with Ukraine
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with the ministerial colleagues and
others in addition to my duties in this
house I shall have further such meetings
later today Andrew West thank you Mr
Speaker and can I associate myself with
the prime minister's comments with
regard to The Bravery of the Ukrainian
people
labor have asked his government on three
occasions to commit to a police response
to every domestic abuse call to date no
answer has been forthcoming could the
Prime Minister provide a response today
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker just this week we
announced new measures to tackle
violence against women and girls this is
a government that introduced The
Landmark Domestic Abuse Act that's
rolling out specialist advisors for
those who suffer and putting more
funding to support victims we will
continue to do everything we can to make
sure that women and girls are safe
everywhere in our country
the warm welcome given to Ukrainian
refugees by so many is extremely
heartwarming does the Prime Minister
understand though how upset my
constituents are to have bookings for
weddings and other special family events
canceled when the home office took over
a much-loved hotel and will he redouble
his efforts to put an end to this
practice
[Applause]
well I uh my honorable friends
constituents and indeed the whole
country can be proud of the welcome that
they have given to people from Ukraine
over the last year and I can assure him
that we are committed to reducing the
number of Asylum Seekers living in
hotels at vast cost of taxpayers and
considerable disruption to communities
I'm grateful to the leadership of the
Home Secretary and the immigration
minister in finding a sustainable
solution and the Home Secretary will
make a formal update in the coming weeks
on progress and standing up alternative
sites for accommodation when our club's
the leader of the opposition
uh thank you Mr Speaker can I join the
prime minister in his comments about
Ukraine I had the privilege last week of
seeing firsthand the courage and
resilience of the Ukrainian people and
we must continue to stand United in this
house in support of Ukraine
Mr Speaker can I also say that the
thoughts of the whole house I'm sure the
whole country will be with the family of
Nicola bully at this very very difficult
time
how can I welcome a new member for West
Lancashire
her first PM fuse
Mr Speaker the labor party is proud to
be the party of the Good Friday
agreement and peace and prosperity in
Northern Ireland we welcome attempts to
make the protocol work more effectively
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that it has been poorly implemented and
that the basis for any deal must be
removing unnecessary checks on Goods
Prime Minister well Mr Mr Speaker let me
welcome the honor related to her place
and associate myself with the remarks of
The Honorable gentleman about Nicola
Bully's family our thoughts are of
course with them as he knows we are
still in active discussions with the
European Union but he should know that I
am a conservative a brexiter and a
unionist in any agreement that we reach
needs to tick all three boxes it needs
to ensure sovereignty
for Northern Ireland and it's a
safeguard Northern Ireland's place in
our Union and it needs to find practical
solutions to the problems faced by
people and businesses I will be Resolute
in fighting for what is best for
Northern Ireland and the United Kingdom
Mr Speaker we all agree that the
protocol can be improved
but there are trade-offs and we need to
face up to them his predecessor told
businesses that there would be no forms
no checks no barriers of any kind
that was absolute nonsense and it
destroyed trust so in the interest of
restoring that trust trust will he
confirm that to avoid a hard border on
the island of Ireland the deal he's
negotiating is going to see Northern
Ireland continue to follow some EU law
Mr Speaker I think that the honorable
gentleman is jumping ahead we are still
we are still
we are still in intensive intensive
discussions with the European Union to
ensure that we can find agreement that
meets the test that I said and that is
sovereignty for Northern Ireland it's
Northern Ireland's place in our precious
Union and it is to find practical
solutions to the problems faced by
people and businesses I've spent time
engaging and listening to those
communities in Northern Ireland
businesses and political parties I have
a good understanding of what is required
and I will keep fighting until we get it
foreign Mr Speaker the prime minister is
biting his tongue but at some point the
irreconcilables on his benches are going
to Twig and they're going to come after
him the former trade Minister says there
can be no role for the European court of
justice in Northern Ireland
so will the Prime Minister be honest
with them and tell them that's not going
to happen
[Applause]
Mr speaker now again we need to keep
going to actually secure an acceptable
agreement but for the honorable
gentleman to be talking about a deal
that he hasn't even seen that with
[Applause]
negotiating
usual position when it comes to the
European Union it's it's give the EU a
blank check and agree to anything they
offer
it's not it's not a strategy Mr Speaker
that's surrender
speaker
Mr Speaker
it's not my question says avoiding it's
their question so he's avoiding
his predecessors wasted months pushing
the Northern Ireland protocol Bill if
implemented it would tie us up in
battles with the EU the United States
and others at precisely the time we
should be building common ground to
boost our economy and show Unity against
Putin now the Prime Minister clearly
wants a closer relationship with the EU
so can he confirm that if there's a deal
he will pull the protocol bill
Minister Mr Speaker look what the The
Honorable gentleman wants to put the EU
first I want to put Northern Ireland
first
questions
and on these questions The Honorable
gentleman said he would respect the
result of the referendum and then he
promised to back a second one
all the while he was constantly voting
to frustrate brexit and I know what the
British people know that on this
question he can't be trusted to stick up
for Britain
Mr Speaker the sound you hear is them
cheering the Prime Minister pulling the
wool over their eyes
[Applause]
fifth anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement the 30th anniversary of the
Downing Street declaration Tony Blair
and John Major both recognized that
politics in Northern Ireland is built on
trust and not telling people what they
want to hear and the need to take
seriously the concerns of both
communities nationalists and unionists
it's vital their voices are heard so can
the Prime Minister confirm that whatever
deal he brings back this house will get
a vote on it
prime minister Mr Speaker of course of
course Parliament will express its view
but what is crucial but what what is
crucial here
but what is crucial here is that it is
not this is not about his desire to play
political games in this house with this
situation this is n't what is best for
the people and communities of Northern
Ireland
are that Mr Speaker is what I will keep
fighting for
well Mr Speaker I take it from that that
this house will get a vote and I look
forward to that vote in due course
because everyone knows the basis of this
deal has been agreed for weeks but it's
the same old Story the country has to
wait while he plucks up the courage to
take home the malcontents The Reckless
the Wreckers on his own benches but I'm
here to tell him he doesn't need to
worry about that because we will put
country before party and Ensure labor
votes to get it through he should accept
our offer ignore the house of
indignation from those on his side who
will never take yes for an answer why
doesn't he just get on with it
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker what what I am
doing is talking and listening to the
people of Northern Ireland that is the
right thing to do it's to make sure that
we can respond and resolve to the
concerns of the unious communities and
businesses in Northern Ireland and that
is what I will keep doing but Mr Speaker
we know that the underground General
talks about his plans we have heard that
tomorrow he's going to announce five
missions but we all we all we already
know what they are it's uncontrolled
immigration it's Reckless spending it's
higher debt and its softer sentences and
for the fifth pledge the fifth pledge Mr
Speaker we all know it's that he
reserves the right to change his mind on
the other four
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker last year the
coroner determined that content promoted
at Molly Russell that promoted
self-harming suicide contributed to her
death but they weren't able to make that
decision after years of campaigning by
the Russell family and the coroners to
gain access to that information does the
Prime Minister agree with me that other
families should not have to suffer as
the Russell family have suffered and
that relevant data data relevance the
death of a child should be more readily
available both to families and to the
coroner service than it currently is
prime minister
uh can I join my writable friend in
paying tribute to the Russell family for
their tireless and dignified campaigning
on behalf of all families who have been
bereaved in such tragic circumstances
the companies already have coroners
rather already have statutory powers to
require evidence to be given or produced
for the purposes of their investigation
but the government is listening
carefully to the concerns of
parliamentary colleagues and to bury
families the ministry of justice and
department for science innovation
technology are leading those discussions
to ensure that we have the right set of
procedures in place we now come to the
leader of the SMP Stephen Flynn yeah
Mr Speaker wholesale wholesale gas
prices
have fallen by 75 since their Peak yet
in just a matter of weeks the British
government the Westminster government
intends to increase energy bills by a
further 500 pounds what would motivate a
prime minister to do such a thing yeah
the Prime Minister Mr Mr Speaker what we
are doing is providing tens of billions
of pounds of support for people with
their energy bills particularly the most
vulnerable what we're also doing opposed
by the SMP is to invest in producing
more home-grown gas here in the UK and
the North Sea but I would say to The
Honorable gentleman as one of his own I
I saw one of his own members of
parliament said this week that if the
SMP were a pizza company their products
would be slow wrong and costly
to him it's time to focus on the issues
that matter to the people of Scotland
and producing more energy is absolutely
one of them
for sure that inferring that energy
bills Mr Speaker don't matter to the
people of Scotland it's a winning
strategy for this prime minister but
let's get real the fact that wholesale
gas prices have fallen by 75 means a
windfall to the Prime Minister and the
chancellor of around 15 billion pounds
so what they're saying as it stands that
they intend to read the pockets of
ordinary Scots whilst lining the pockets
of Westminster Mr Speaker it's time to
set aside it is time to set aside any
notion of an energy Place increase
instead protect households and perhaps
reduce bills by 500 pounds does he not
agree
Mr Speaker we're saving households
across the United Kingdom including in
Scotland 900 pounds with their energy
bills as a result of our energy bills
guarantee and in the coming years we
will spend 12 billion pounds protecting
particularly the most vulnerable
families pensioners across the United
Kingdom but the best way the best way to
reduce people's bills is to halve
inflation as we have promised to do and
it is to produce more homegrown energy
here in the United Kingdom that's
something that this government supports
maybe he could confirm whether the SMP
supports that
you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister will
be well aware of the dogger Campaign Of
The Honorable member for Northwest
Norfolk for a rebuild of the Queen
Elizabeth Hospital in King's Lynn it's a
hospital constructed from failing
aerated Concrete where ceilings are Now
supported by more than 3 000 wooden and
metal props but is the prime minister
also aware of the strength of feeling
locally in support of the rebuild not
just in Northwest Norfolk but in
broadland North Norfolk Norwich North
mid Norfolk Southwest Norfolk Huntington
North West Cambridgeshire and South
Holland in the Deep links whose
populations are all served by this
hospital will he support our campaign
can I thank my honorable friend and
indeed the uh my little friend from
Northwest Norfolk because I know they
are great supporters of this project and
I know over the last year or so the
Queen Elizabeth Hospital has been
allocated over 50 million pounds to
address the most immediate issues of the
site but I also know they have expressed
their interest in being part of the new
hospital program the department is
looking through all those bids he'll
know that I can't comment on specific
ones but the selected hospitals will be
announced in due course so Jeffrey
Donalds speaker can I thank the Prime
Minister for his efforts uh in relation
to the Northern Ireland protocol
acceptable that Northern Ireland has
been put in this place with a protocol
imposed upon us that harms our place in
the United Kingdom
must be replaced with Arrangements that
are acceptable and restore our place in
the United Kingdom on its internal
Market
does the Prime Minister accept how
important the Constitutional and
Democratic issues are in relation to
getting a solution and will he agree
with me that it is unacceptable that EU
laws are imposed on Northern Ireland
with no Democratic scrutiny or consent
and will he assure me that he will
address these fundamental constitutional
issues and do so not just by tweaking
the protocol but by rewriting the
legally binding treaty text the prime
minister
can I thank the right honorable
gentleman for his question but also
thank him for the role that he has
played in recent months in articulating
unionist concerns I've heard loud and
clear when he says he wants and needs
these issues resolved so that he has a
basis to work with others to restore
power sharing and I know that that is
genuine he raised the question of
practical issues and it is vital that
these are addressed but he also raises
Mr Speaker a vital question about the
Constitutional and legal framework in
which these Arrangements exist and I can
assure him that I agree addressing the
Democratic deficit is an essential part
of the negotiations that remain ongoing
with the European Union and just as he
has been consistent so have I and I can
assure him that this is at the very
heart of the issues that must be
addressed it's about big
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
has made fixing illegal immigration
across the channel one of his key top
priorities he's also said that
legislation will be required to stop it
I completely agree so can he tell us
when we can expect to see this
legislation coming forward as time is of
the essence and can he explain why
sorting out this issue did not feature
on the home office permanent secretary
stated top three priorities for his
Department
prime minister well uh Mr Speaker Thank
The Honorable uh my honorable friend for
her for her question she's right illegal
Crossings put people's lives at risk it
diverts resources away from those in
genuine need and it's unfair on those
who migrate here legally and that's why
one of our five pledges to the British
people is to stop the boats we are
working at PACE on the legislation it's
important that it works and in the
meantime our deals with Albania and
France are already yielding benefits but
what I can tell her is that we want a
system whereby if someone arrives in our
country illegally they will not be able
to stay instead they will be detained
and removed to a country that they come
from or a safe third alternative that is
the system that the Home Secretary and I
are working hard to to put in place and
that is what our legislation will
deliver talk about juicing nothing
thanks to the prime minister's policies
we are now inflicted with the highest
tax burden and the biggest drop in
disposable income since the second world
war and to make matters worse tens of
billions of pounds of taxpayer money was
wasted on a world beating test and Trace
system billions on PP that wasn't even
fit for purpose not to mention the
endless list of crony covered contracts
going to Tory Chums who profited at the
expense of other people's misery so when
will the Prime Minister help us to
recover some of that lost money so that
striking nurses teachers and other
public servants can be paid the decent
wage that they so richly deserve
well Mr Mr Speaker I'm uh I'm very
pleased that the government is in
intensive talks with the Royal College
of Nursing to find a way forward as I've
always said we are Keen to discuss these
terms and conditions and I'm glad that
those conversations are now happening
well I'd say to honorable gentleman is
he really cares about the impact of
working people than maybe him and his
party should stand up to their union pay
masters and back our minimum service
laws
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to thank
the Prime Minister for his support in
the law launch of the new regulatory
Reform Group would the Prime Minister
commit to working with our group in two
specific areas the first to improve the
accountability and responsiveness of our
Regulators to both stakeholders and to
Parliament and secondly to improve the
economic potential in key growing areas
of the economy such as Financial
Services artificial intelligence and
advanced manufacturing prime minister
well uh my model makes an excellent
point and he's right about the
importance of getting our regulatory
framework right to drive growth and
prosperity that's why my right normal
friend the chancellor has set out an
extensive review of retained EU law in
five key growth areas including Life
Sciences green Industries and digital
technology but also the government Chief
Scientific Advisor is leading work to
consider how the UK can better regulate
emerging Technologies enabling their
rapid and safe introduction and David
it was a pleasure to meet the delegation
from Key before questions and to confirm
that across this house we are united in
our support for Ukraine and its Brave
Heroes
Mr Speaker the conservative Manifesto
promised 40 new hospitals
after three years most of these
hospitals haven't even got planning
permission yet and communities feel
betrayed and taken for granted
as ITV showed yesterday Saint helier
hospital in South London is literally
crumbling but there's still no plan to
save it hinging Brook Hospital in
Cambridgeshire has sewage leaking into
its Wards and a roof that could collapse
at any moment does the Prime Minister
agree that these are conditions no
patients doctors or nurses should have
to put up with can he tell the house
[Applause]
prime minister John just before we do
please don't take advantage of the other
people
[Applause]
uh Mr Speaker I'm proud that we're
investing record sums into the NHS under
this government also record sums in NHS
Capital not just going on upgrading
almost 100 hospitals developing 40
large-scale developments as The
Honorable gentleman knows but also
investing in more scanners more
ambulances across the board so we can
deliver vital care to people and I'm
very pleased that the most recent
statistics on urgent Emergency Care show
considerable improvement from the
challenges we faced over December and we
now are on a clear path to getting
people the treatment they need in the
time that they need it two o'clock
the government's commitment to tackling
illegal migration and particularly the
issue of small boats but can I ask my
right honorable friends if he will
reconsider the government's proposal to
relocate approximately 500 single male
Asylum Seekers to be consigned in
Stafford and can I ask him to meet with
me urgently to discuss this given the
huge amount of objections I've received
from constituents on this issue prime
minister
well firstly Mr Speaker can I welcome my
honorable friend back to her place and I
know that this is an issue that is
concerning her and her constituents and
it's why we must absolutely stop the
boats and stem the tide of illegal
migrants to relieve this pressure on our
local communities but I will ensure that
she meets with the Home Secretary as
soon as possible to discuss her concerns
and hopefully we can arrange that
meeting in the coming days John McNally
uh thank you Mr Speaker this month's the
Scottish scale payment marks its
two-year anniversary yeah then a cost of
what increases this policy has been a
Lifeline to hundreds of thousands of
people in Scotland therefore will the
Prime Minister follow the leadership of
the Scottish government and introduce an
equivalent trial payment yeah
well I'm uh Mr Speaker that the best way
to ensure uh that children grow up not
in poverty is to make sure they grow up
in order to grow up in a workless
household and that's why I'm proud that
under the record of the conservative
government there are almost a million
fewer children growing up in workless
households hundreds of thousands fewer
children in poverty and that's because
this government is on the side of
parents and will make sure that they
have the jobs they need because
ultimately that is the best poverty
strategy is to have everybody in work
thank you Mr Speaker I previously called
out in this house the appalling level of
service that my constituents and viewers
received from train operator
transpennine last month transpennine had
the largest number of cancellations of
any service provider in the UK but it
turns out that even this figure was
fiddled because transpennine had
canceled over a thousand trains before
10 30 the night before so that they
don't show up in the statistics does the
Prime Minister agree with me that this
practice is totally unacceptable as is
their level of service
well I I agree with my right honorable
friend the current service levels are
unacceptable the rail North partnership
which is managing the contract is
working with the company on an
improvement plan my honorable friend the
rail minister is having weekly meetings
with royal North partnership to monitor
its progress and whilst the transpenline
contract expires in May and we are
working on a new contract if minister
conclude that the operator cannot be
turned around then other decisions may
have to be made let's support
thank you Mr Speaker of the 40 promised
new hospitals referred to by my right
honorable friend 11 of those are in the
southwest of England three of them
surround my constituency in Barnstable
Dorchester and Taunton but none of them
has planning permission it's been
reported that staff at Eastbourne
District General Hospital were told that
their time would not get a new hospital
and that it was quote a bare-faced lie
given that the Prime Minister claims his
mandate rests on a Manifesto that
promised 40 new hospitals when will we
see them
well Mr Speaker the government is
committed to building 40 new hospitals
as part of the new hospital program in
the Southwest eight eight out of the 11
schemes do have full outline planning
permission approved and the remaining
three schemes due to when they are
delivered due to be delivered would not
be expected to have planning permission
at this stage and we're working with the
trust to go through that process so
everything is on track and we will bring
those hospitals to the people in the
southwestern
there's three million pounds sent to
Wolverhampton to trial the new Better
Health app which will support wolf
Rooney and make better choices about
their diet and fitness will he welcome
this and also celebrate our Grassroots
sports clubs in Wolverhampton especially
wentzfield Aces cycle Speedway Club who
celebrated their Diamond Jubilee last
year
well well Mr Mr Speaker can I join a
honorable friend in commending all her
local sporting organizations for the job
they do and she's absolutely right that
prevention is absolutely better than a
cure and ensuring that we can support
people to live healthy fulfilling lives
is absolutely part of our plan and
that's why we're investing in football
pitchers tennis courts and youth
facilities right up and down the country
and I'm glad that her constituents are
benefiting Morgan thank you Mr Speaker
the government hasn't only broken its
promises on new hospitals it's also
broken its plan of 6 000 more doctors
with a number of qualified GPS having
actually Fallen GPS and Shropshire are
seeing 400 more patients each than they
were in 2016 which is one of the biggest
rises in the Country Places across the
country East Sussex Devon Cambridge and
Hampshire have also seen the number of
qualified GPS for where will the Prime
Minister and his the government's
neglect of local health services and
recruit and retain the GPS we need well
let's Mr Speaker that the the fact of
this there are 2 200 more GPS in general
practice today there are 15 000 more
doctors in the NHS and there are 30 000
more nurses and that's because we're
putting record funding in and backing
the NHS and getting patients the care
that they need
thank you Mr Speaker
can I commend my honorable my right
humble friend in season grasping the
nettle and seeking to negotiate an
agreement on the Northern Ireland
protocol yeah does he share my
frustration with the express views of
people who are commenting upon a deal
that has yet to be reached and does he
agree with me that the best way to
reduce or even end the jurisdiction of
the CJ EU is through treaty change it
change itself and not through domestic
legislation in this Parliament prime
minister Mr Mr Speaker my right
honorable friend is absolutely right we
need to keep going but he's also right
that we need to find enduring solutions
to the challenges faced by the people of
Northern Ireland and that's why as the
uh my honorable friend mentioned earlier
it is absolutely right that we address
the Constitutional legal framework of
our arrangements and ensure that we can
put in place new Arrangements that
secure Northern Ireland's place in the
United Kingdom that Western thank you Mr
Speaker the prime minister is no
stranger to being fined
to the EU after the UK government
allowed Chinese forbsters to flood
Europe with cheap Goods is the worst
waste of public money my question is
simple if you can find 2.53 billion
pounds to pay a fine why can't you pay
NHS workers and others the pay increases
they deserve
oh Mr Speaker he may he may not have
seen that the Royal College of Nursing
are now in talks with the government
about result resolving the disputes and
I'm grateful to them I'm grateful to
them for entering to those talks with a
spirit of a constructive attitude but
also to calling off their strikes next
week but I would urge him and his
colleagues to do is be on the side of
working people and that's to back our
Lords to introduce minimum safety levels
across the NHS and transport because
that's the best way to demonstrate that
you're on the side of hard-working
families Mr Speaker
I wholeheartedly support my prime
minister's priority to stop the boats so
could he please bring in the small boat
spill next week
I thank my honorable friend for his
support I share with him the same desire
which is to stop the boat for all the
reasons that we've discussed in this
session and he should rest assured that
the Home Secretary and I are working
intensely and as quickly as possible to
bring forward that legislation because
what I want is what he wants is to
ensure that those people who come here
really illegally will simply not be
allowed to stay Charlotte
cue Mr Speaker during recess my
community in Warrington was rocked by
the murder of 16 year old school girl
Brianna Jai what support will the Prime
Minister offer to our community and to
our local schools in order to ensure
that they have the support that they
need to support Brianna's classmates and
her family as we try to heal from this
appalling tragedy prime minister
well can I can I thank my The Honorable
lady for raising this issue and express
my sympathies to around his family and
friends for what's happened I know she
will be playing her part in her local
community in supporting them at this
difficult time I know the Home Secretary
is shortly due to visit the area and she
will be able to discuss with the
honorable lady what support can be
provided to support the community at a
time like this and she should know that
she will have what she needs from the
government final question I'm turning
back from Mr Speaker I can't ask the
prime ministers to stop time or Tide but
I might ask him to offset it because in
South Devon the slapton line is being
eroded away and I need him to help me
Lobby the department for transport and
the defra secretary to see that we can
get the repairs done because Natural
England is standing in the way of this
vital link and stopping us from doing
the developments that we need to do will
he support me prime minister Mr Mr
Speaker honorable friend is a fantastic
campaigner and advocate for his
constituents I know that this particular
issue is causing frustration and concern
in his community he's absolutely right
to raise it I will ensure that he gets
the appropriate meetings he needs with
the ministers in question so we can work
with him to try and find a resolution
that completes prime minister's
questions
but we're going to discuss what happened
to pmqs with our political editor Beth
Rigby in a moment but a couple bits of
breaking news to bring you that have
occurred while we've been watching that
the queen consort has pulled out of
another visit uh she was going to go
into the Felix project charity in London
with the King she is continuing to
recover from covert Buckner Palace said
and she has a busy day ahead of her
tomorrow so it's taking it easy today in
the hope that she'll be well enough to
be out and about tomorrow also uh the
inquest into the death of Nicola bully
has been opened and adjourned at lancast
Lancashire Coroner's court and they have
heard in the last few minutes that she
was identified by her dental records the
family not in attendance at the inquest
which was very brief a short time ago
final bit of breaking news London
Underground drivers are to strike on the
15th of March a significant day because
it's budget day and a dispute over
pensions and working Arrangements that's
from their Union as left we'll be
getting more on that I'm sure throughout
the rest of the day uh in the meantime
let's present to prime minister's
questions our political editor Beth
Rigby is here and Beth Maps no surprise
Northern Ireland really dominating the
agenda for the Prime Minister yeah very
much so and Kate what kills starmer did
there was he asked him a series of quite
detailed questions knowing that Rishi
Suna was not going to stand at that
dispatch box and answer them in any way
while these negotiations are still going
on I should say as well that it has been
very tightly held someone told me that
one of the ministers Steve Baker who's a
key brexiteer wasn't even brought into
the room in terms of finding out what
any detail of a deal was until Monday uh
this week so everyone being kept out of
the loop apart from a core around the
Prime Minister which means the dup don't
necessarily know the Contours of the
deal the brexiteer wing of the party the
ERG don't either and kirstan were there
for asking the Prime Minister questions
really that he knew the Prime Minister
wouldn't answer around the role of the
European court of justice in post-brexit
trading Arrangements in Northern Ireland
a big red line for many brexiteers the
role of EU legislation determining uh
issues around Goods in Northern Ireland
you heard Jeffrey Donaldson there the
dup leader saying that there was no
sense of checks or any Democratic
consent that these rules were imposed on
the dup buyers they would put it a
foreign government or a foreign body and
they don't have any recourse on that so
that's a red line for them so how does
that affect the deal so really asking
the Prime Minister questions that he
couldn't and wouldn't answer and then
obviously handing him or offering him
the poison chalice at the end saying
well if your own backbenches won't put
this deal through the commons for you
we're here willing and ready to help and
of course politically this is exactly
the sort of trouble Theresa May got into
when you remember those long brexit Wars
uh back in 2018 into 2019 and of course
Boris Johnson went on to become the
conservative party leader in the summer
of 2019 and really this is a prime
minister with a a problem in terms of
he's got to get the dup on board he then
has to try and get the brexiteers on
board all the while there is Boris
Johnson waiting in the wings probably
very happy to agitate if he sees these
divisions playing out uh against the
prime minister so it's a really
difficult tightrope that Rishi sunak is
walking and what you saw there was not
opsification but you saw a prime
minister that couldn't answer the
questions and it just gives a sense of
for all the momentum that number 10 had
last week in the sense that this deal
was going to get done where she sooner
was going to unlock the problems that
have you know besieged previous uh
conservative Prime Ministers and and
sought out once and for all the problems
around post-brexit trading Arrangements
in Northern Ireland you know with every
day that passes it seems like that that
that quick solution is not there and
there's a lot of intensive negotiations
this is a prime minister that's been in
talks with the dup and the ERG and key
brexiteers all week trying to sort out a
deal because he can strike a deal with
Brussels but if he can't sell it to the
dup and the ERG that creates problems
not least because it means that the
parish sharing arrangement in Northern
Ireland can't get up and running again
and isn't that really the point of all
of this to restore that power sharing
Arrangement within Northern Ireland and
also on his own back benches all of the
problems that were still there after Liz
truss was deposed and Rishi suno put in
place they haven't gone away they're
just under the surface and this now
threatens to really bring back those
internal conservative divisions so it
wasn't a lively prime minister's
questions was it no but it was
significant in terms of what it's
telling us not about the relationship
really between Kirsty sunak but what
it's telling us about the problems that
Rishi sunak now has with the back
benches and a massive wedge of them that
always wanted Boris Johnson to remain
prime minister and would very much like
Boris Johnson back in power it is
interesting though in the sense that
you're talking about people being kept
out of the room
it's it suggests that the talks are
actually achieving something that there
is progress being made if there's stuff
that they don't want people to know
about it means that they're actually
getting stuff agreed doesn't it stuff
that they don't want people to know
about worries that it's going to leak I
think the issue is around these
negotiations which previous Prime
Ministers and people that I've spoken to
that were familiar with incarnations of
this uh under Boris Johnson and then
before Boris Johnson under Theresa May
is that for the dup what they want to
see is a legal agreement you heard
Jeffrey Donaldson say it there they want
to see it in black and white they want
the legal text it's the same as the ERG
who will always get lawyers to pour over
these documents and so the issue is is
if you keep everyone out until you
struck a deal with Brussels
and you don't bring these other parties
in then you might you might secure a
deal but if you can't sell the deal what
what is the deal worth and I think
that's been some of the issues around it
which is why the idea that you can just
bring everyone on on board with with
discussing it without actually seeing an
agreement I mean some of the
um brexities that I've spoken to and
certainly uh one of the ministers that
I've spoken to keep saying well we
haven't seen a text yet so some
ministers are on resignation watch and
when you say well what are you thinking
do you think you might have to resign
can you not live with this in good
conscience can you adhere to cabinet and
Collective government Collective
responsibility they want to see the text
and the devil is in the detail if you
like so for all of Rishi sunax typed
negotiations with Brussels he has to
sell it to Northern Ireland and he has
to sell it to his back benches and that
really is always the biggest hurdle in
any of this okay Beth thanks very much
well while that was going on President
Vladimir Putin has been holding a
massive rally in Moscow today it comes
after he met China's top Diplomat in the
Russian capital a little earlier saying
that the two countries have reached new
levels of cooperation
a diplomat Wang Yi is in Russia for
talks on new agreements between Beijing
and Moscow touting the two countries
Partnerships as a new era and that they
continue to operate at a high level he
also said that regardless of the changes
of the international situation China is
willing to maintain a good momentum in
the development of a new model of major
power relationship
well let's go live to Moscow and our
correspondent Diana magnet uh two things
to talk about really Diana but but first
of all in terms of China relations uh
how significant is this visit and the
fact that wangi has now actually met the
the Prime Minister not just Sergey
lavrov
um
tour for one year he was at the Munich
security conference where the U.S
Secretary of State had very Stern words
for him saying uh